today on the matt well show a major
science publication endorses joe biden
hails him as the most pro-science
candidate in the race of course the
democrat party has for years called
itself
the party of science but does it deserve
that label i would say no not remotely
we'll talk about why also five headlines
including president trump's historic
peace deal and the heroic female police
officer
who was shot in that assassination
attempt over the weekend has been
identified
oddly the media not very interested in
her story in our daily cancellation i
will cancel the
cowardly pastor who apologized to his
congregation
uh when his associate pastor criticized
blm during a homily was a great homily
of course i got a criticism from the
pastor we'll talk about that
also today on the show but we start here
the scientific american came out this
week with its first presidential
endorsement in 175
years urging its readers to vote for joe
biden donald trump
claims the publication rejects evidence
and science whereas biden allegedly
has a record of following the data and
being guided by science
now on the heels of this announcement
joe biden's wife jill biden
tweeted hashtag vote for science and
governor andrew cuomo wrote simply
science knows not sure what that means
exactly or what cuomo thinks science
knows hope for his sake that it doesn't
know about the
thousands of nursing home patients he
killed in any case uh many
others on the left and in the media
chimed in hailing biden as
science his guardian and protector and
themselves as its greatest fans
now biden is glad to play this role
speaking in wilmington on monday as we
discussed on the show yesterday
the former vice president spoke about
the need to govern according to science
he also said this just to refresh your
memory
donald trump climate denial
may not have caused these fires and
record floods
and record hurricanes but if he gets a
second term
these hellish events will continue to
become more common
more devastating and more deadly
and meanwhile donald trump warns that
integration is threatening our suburbs
it's ridiculous but you know what is
actually threatening our suburbs
wildfires are burning the suburbs in the
west
floods are wiping out suburban
neighborhoods in the midwest
hurricanes are imperiling suburban life
along our coast
if we have four more years of trump's
climate denial
how many suburbs will be burned in
wildfires
how many suburban neighborhoods will
have been flooded out
how many suburbs will have been blown
away
in superstorms
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
if you give a climate denier four more
years in the white house why would
anyone be surprised
when more of america is underwater
we need a president who respects science
who understands
that the damage from climate change is
already here
unless we take urgent action
will soon be more catastrophic joe biden
patron saint of science apparently
believes that there is some sort of
physical
mechanism by which the president of the
united states can actually
cause hurricanes to materialize and
flood waters to rise
now he's not talking about humans merely
contributing
in some partial way to gradual changes
in climate over the course of many
decades
he's suggesting that one single human on
earth today can through his own
exertions
have a material impact on global weather
conditions
so when biden and his supporters speak
of science
this is what they mean but at least
biden's theory of climate change is
slightly less crazy
than crazy nancy pelosi's who recently
speculated that wildfires happen
because mother earth is angry she is
telling us the climate crisis is real
we'll play that again too just to just
so we can relive it here it is
we have these fires in california and in
the west
of 16 people have died in washington
oregon
and california including a firefighter
and a one-year-old baby
we our firefighters have been so very
very courageous
now we're again breaking records mother
earth is angry she's
telling us whether she's telling us with
hurricanes on the gulf coast
fires in the west whatever it is that
the climate crisis
is real and has an impact so the idea
that natural
disasters are the result of a displeased
earth goddess
may have passed for science among
ancient tribes in the year 6000 bc but
it's a bit outmoted in the modern age
yet this again is what we get from the
party
of science party of science also tells
us that uh the child conceived by two
human beings and developing in the womb
of his mother
is not fully human or not fully person
or not fully alive they can't really
make up their mind
as an msnbc anchor once put it the
answer to when life begins
quote depends an awful lot on the
feelings of the parents
these same custodians and conservators
of science say that
a male can have a functioning female
reproductive system
a female can have a penis and a y
chromosome or perhaps
say the the science lovers a person may
have no gender at all they may be
gender fluid possessing no discernible
form just
lumps of ambiguous beings slithering
aimlessly over the earth
once again science now i have personally
asked
as i mentioned before i've asked two
prominent leftists with doctorates one a
medical doctor the other a supposed
internationally recognized expert on
sexuality to define the words man and
woman
and neither of these left-wing science
experts with phds could do it
dr eugene goo told me that a man can be
identified as
anyone who identifies as a man and
doctor
logan lefkoff insisted that a woman is
quote anything she wants to be
now the latter answer might make a good
inspirational slogan for a guidance
counselor's bulletin board but
it is not science perhaps the situation
can be
maybe summarized this way the side of
the political isle that talks the most
about science
and most trumpets its own commitment to
the methods of science
also believes that it's possible that a
man who is pregnant with a non-human
fetus
might die in a hurricane caused by the
president
that's all that needs to be said to
establish that the party of science has
rather
failed to live up to its assumed name
and this should be no surprise
i mean how could a worldview that is so
committed to relativism have any real
commitment to science science after all
is the study of what is
it's the struggle to understand reality
on its own terms to think scientifically
about objective reality
you must first admit that there is such
a thing and that its rules and laws
cannot be changed for your sake and that
you are at least in strictly physical
terms
but a speck of dust on a slightly bigger
speck of dust hurtling through
the abyss face reality and accept your
real place in it that must be the
starting point
for any scientific inquiry but that's
not something that the modern left can
or will do it claims that reality is
bendable and mutable according to the
will of the individual
and that any difficult facts about the
world or ourselves
can be simply wished away that's the
opposite of science
and when enough people adopt that way of
thinking the leftist way of thinking
it is the death of science this
mentality has seeped into our scientific
scientific institutions so-called
scientists and doctors
coming out now saying that white
supremacy is a public health crisis
there's no justification for this
there's no evidence it's not science
but they want it to be true so they say
that it is
meanwhile psychologists and doctors have
legitimized the idea that a young boy
can have a girl stuck in his body
in some mysterious dualistic way and
that the best way to treat this
condition is to give him hormone pills
this is dogma belief faith superstition
voodoo it is many things science is not
is not
on the list though you know what else is
part of science
skepticism if you care about science if
you believe science
if you trust and follow science if you
think science knows whatever that means
then you're a skeptic and you respect
and welcome skepticism that doesn't mean
you have to be agnostic about everything
it just means that
you ask questions uh you think
critically
you don't accept anything as fact based
solely on the insistence of some
other person if somebody makes a claim
you're likely to respond
oh why do you think that or how do you
know or
even better why should i believe that
that's skepticism
it's healthy it's necessary science
cannot exist without it
but skepticism too in our culture is
rejected shouted down skeptics are
burned at the stake metaphorically
perhaps soon not so metaphorically take
the issue with masks for example
a skeptic says oh well what's the
science behind this
are we sure that it works are we sure
it's not doing more harm than good
how sure are we why are we sure if we're
sure at all
what's the evidence these are valid
questions intelligent
skeptical questions scientific questions
but the alleged lovers of science will
pelt you with rocks if you so much as
whisper them so many of the people who
say they love science
actually hate it and are extremely
antagonistic towards it
democrats are not the party of science
and the left
are not the champions of science and our
culture so far as it is driven by these
forces
is not one that is friendly to science
or truth for that matter
in any other form let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know these days uh it's it's really
important to find companies that support
our values
it's one thing you know you're looking
for products and services that you
that you want and that are right for you
for your family but the other problem is
that we run into as conservatives
is that so often you end up supporting
companies that don't support you and
that are actively working against you in
the culture
and that's something we struggle with i
think as conservatives all the time
here's a solution to that problem at
least in one area the pro-life phone
company charity mobile
uh you got to support this this company
because they support us they support
what we believe in
if you if you go with charity mobile 5
of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
uh the great thing is new activations
eligible accounts also get a free cell
phone with a free activation
and free shipping credit check required
uh on that
but so you're getting you're supporting
a cause
that you believe in the most really the
most important cause in the culture
which is a pro-life cause
but you're also getting a great service
as well no contracts no termination fees
no risk with a 30-day guarantee also you
get live customer service
and it's based right here in the usa and
you get all kinds of other
frills that go with it you can you can
block use of cellular data
picture messages text messages on any
lines on your account
you get free usage alerts you get a free
app to monitor your your usage you could
so you could pay your bill and uh and
you know i think most importantly all of
all though you can help build a culture
of life in america
while supporting a pro-life company
this means that you can turn every day
into sort of effortless giving for the
charity of your choice
uh america's largest and most reliable
4g lte network
um you also get with with charity mobile
i've been using charity mobile for
several months now and it just feels
good to know that i've got a great
service but i'm also
supporting uh the cause that i believe
in uh
most of all which is the pro-life cause
you can call charity mobile at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com all right
let's get to our
five headlines and i don't have this
actually written down as a headline but
i saw it right before
we started here that cardi b is getting
divorced so very sad development i feel
like that should be the number one
cardi b was married to a gentleman named
offset i don't know if that was his
christian name
greatest romance of our time cardi b an
offset and they are
getting divorced you know who would have
ever thought that rolling around on the
floor naked
and singing about your whop may not be
the healthiest thing for your marriage
i i didn't see i could i couldn't i
never could have seen that coming
but all of our hearts are breaking today
um all right anyway let's get to the
real headlines
reading from fox news says on tuesday
president trump was joined by
israeli president benjamin netanyahu uae
foreign minister abdullah
bin zayed al-nayhan and bahrain foreign
minister
khalid bin ahmed al-khalif there we go
to sign the abraham accords something
the president hailed as the dawn of a
new
middle east however says fox cnn's
coverage of the event
was less focused on the groundbreaking
peace agreement and instead shamed the
white house
for holding such an event amid a
pandemic during the network's 3pm
program cnn anchor brook baldwin accused
the president of denying the science
there we go
of coronavirus citing the over 195 000
deaths
um she later negatively emphasized the
hundreds of people that attended the
outdoor
white house event and knocked the
president for holding a packed indoor
event
in arizona okay so there you go of
course cnn has to you know find
something else to focus on
you've got a historic peace deal this is
what they're this is what they've got
they're going with because they're
pathetic frauds
but i will say putting cnn to the side
on this peace agreement i've criticized
trump plenty
uh and with no aggress no regrets about
that
but the man has been i think pretty
easily
uh the best foreign policy president
in decades at least and i'd give him
that title just simply based on the fact
that he hasn't started any new wars
and it's sort of sad that that's where
the bar is right now don't start a new
war and you're the best
foreign policy present in a generation
but but uh that that is where it is and
now you add this on top of it and i
think
easily he wins as best foreign policy
president uh
in in decades in my lifetime really
number two on the
uh one of the sheriff's deputies who was
shot in that assassination attempt
in los angeles over the weekend has been
identified her name is claudia
appalinar 31 years old mother
was a librarian before becoming a cop
and she's currently still in the
hospital under guard for her own safety
of course
expected to recover thankfully now this
is a pretty remarkable story
you got a young woman young mother
decides to leave her job as a librarian
gets into law enforcement not but a year
maybe a little bit over a year into
becoming a deputy she's
shot in the face and the torso multiple
times and what does she do
you know there's the video of this with
a with a bullet wound in her
face bleeding profusely hardly able to
speak
presumably in intense unimaginable pain
she helps her partner apply a tourniquet
you know for all she knows she's moments
away from death and what is she doing
she's
she's caring for her partner this is
real heroism i mean this is a badass
woman right here this is what that is
so why isn't the left champion
championing her why aren't they blaring
the trumpets
about this story why aren't they telling
her story at all this is a hero woman
uh it's it seems like also a hispanic
woman
taking care of her male partner after
sustaining a gunshot wound to the face
you think this would be the kind of
story that our liberal friends would eat
up
i mean they're constantly coming out
with movies um with with
fake versions of kick-ass females who do
this kind of thing
here's the real thing the real item in
the flesh
and they don't seem very excited about
it we all know why because the left has
devolved to the point where they aren't
allowed to celebrate
or honor anyone who is not a violent
criminal
all of their heroes recently are violent
criminals they have no
heroic heroes all of their heroes are
scumbags who happen to get shot by the
cop
cops that's that's the requirement for
being a hero on the left today
being a real hero disqualifies you um
that's the left but the rest of us the
rest of us can honor and celebrate this
woman incredible story there
uh number three you may have noticed
that those riots in lancaster that we
talked about
to start the week seem to dissipate
pretty quickly
um one night of rioting and then
it's it's done that we haven't heard
anything else about lancaster
now this is in contrast to portland
seattle where it went on
for months on end kenosha it went on for
weeks
in lancaster one night and it's done
why is that well i think this might help
solve the puzzle
according to the new york post several
of the rioters arrested are now facing
one million dollars bail now you can see
right here
uh this is the their mug shots one of
them is a
the the blonde chick there one of them
she's a sorority girl apparently
and now she's in jail and she can't get
out she's got a million dollars bill
um they're all learning you know this is
what happens when you pull this crap out
in the country
and it's not just bail police in
lancaster they came down
hard on the rioters they were using tear
gas
the very first night they didn't they
didn't they didn't spot the rioters
two weeks to riot before they even tried
to enforce the law no
immediately they were out there with
with uh in full force
tear gas and um and there are videos of
them
you know rolling up in vans not unmarked
vans
liberals who don't need to freak out
about that they are they are marked vans
but they came
they identified the ring leaders of the
rioting
and they singled them out and they they
rolled up in the police fans
and they took them and arrested them and
now they're facing a million dollars
bail
so what do we learn when you give these
punks consequences real consequences the
problem goes away
lancaster came down hard arrested people
harsh penalties what do you know
rioting stops and that's why we don't
need to hear anything about
resources that's one of the excuses
we've heard
in places like portland and seattle we
don't have the resources to
what resources do you think lancaster
has
this is amish country
how often do you think the police
officers in in amish country are dealing
with rioting
it's probably the first time ever and
yet they were able to put it down that
quickly
simply through enforcing the law and
having real consequences because most of
these people that are out riding
they don't want any part of that they're
doing it for fun they're doing it
because they're nihilists they're doing
it because
they've got misdirected rage and they're
just in there and they're they're just
spraying it in every direction
you start you start making it real for
them and it goes away
all right um where are we number four
this is fascinating from the daily wire
again
a group of astrophysicists say they've
accidentally stumbled upon
a possible hint of life on venus
an unexplained chemical that
could indicate the presence of bacteria
or even ongoing activity associated with
specific chemical processes
uh live science reports that the team
was trying to get a baseline read for
phosphine from a planet
uh venus not thought to have phosphite
in the in the atmosphere
and then it turns out that it does and
there's a lot of scientific-y stuff here
that i'm not gonna
read but basically phosphine is a sign
of life
uh because the thing with phosphine is
that it's um
it uh it uh it phosphonates and it
creates a
uh i have no idea actually i have no no
clue whatsoever
but the point is apparently there might
be some kind of life now i'm assuming
that any life
on an 800 degree planet with a toxic
atmosphere probably is not intelligent
we're not looking at an intelligent
civilization uh probably something more
like portland
but either way i you know i i've always
considered it plausible that there could
be intelligent life
in our solar system on other planets if
not venus then maybe mars
and it seems plausible to me that they
could have intelligent civilizations
the reason we don't see them with the
satellites and and the rovers and
everything is that they're hiding
underground
because they don't want us to know about
them they were checking us out and
seeing how things were developing on
earth and they said oh crap
this isn't looking good and so they're
just they're hiding out and waiting for
us to inevitably destroy ourselves and
then they can come back out and uh
live out in the open again the way i
look at it i think earthlings are a
little bit like
you know like the kind of person you
know maybe an acquaintance
who you know and but if you see them at
the grocery store you're going to hide
in the pasta sauce aisle until they
leave
because just because if they're
obnoxious and if you see them they're
going to start talking to you and
they're not going to go away
i think on a galactic scale earth is
probably
a lot like that number five a man in
oregon was arrested for starting a brush
fire
um then then released
so we just talked about how to do this
the right way you know you arrest
people and you keep them this is the
wrong way again because we're back in
oregon so he's arrested for starting a
brush right he's released
then he started six more and was
arrested again
now between this and the gender reveal
party that's that we know also
caused some of these fires the link to
climate change seems to be
um becoming a little bit less clear
shall we say maybe climate change has
driven people mad
and and caused them to start fires and
do gender reveal parties i don't know
i think there was an m night shyamalan
movie that was sort of about that with
mark wahlberg if i'm remembering
correctly what was that movie called
where the the the trees were like
causing people to kill themselves
because
as revenge for deforestation am i making
this up oh it was called the happening
i think that was a movie which by the
way could you think of a lazier name for
a movie than the happening
what should we call the movie i don't
know things are happening in the movie
maybe
the happening um finally we just did
number five here's a bonus i
i can't i can't not play this i really
enjoyed this clip this is nancy pelosi
on cnbc uh yesterday
with jim cramer and here's what happened
what deal can we have a crazy nancy i'm
sorry
that was the president i i i have such
reverence for the office
i would never use that term but it is
like you just did it
but you just did you know what i mean
you know i know what you did
the reference i have for the office is
so great
no he was he was right the first time uh
crazy nancy
that's her name i like how at the end he
goes oh come on you know what i meant
and she says yeah yeah i know what you
meant
well what what what did you mean if not
that she's crazy isn't that what you
meant
um i i and then and then
my next favorite thing is how kramer
emphasizes the respect he has for the
office
not for her but for the office that's a
backhanded compliment which is you know
i would never i have so much respect and
love for
your office your office is what i like
not so much you but your office
um anyway nancy pelosi not having a
great week first someone
poops on her driveway then she's called
crazy on national television
tough week for her pretty enjoyable for
the rest of us but
kind of tough for her all right let's
get to our daily cancellation
today we're going to be canceling with
great wrath and vengeance reverend bob
mccabe
a pastor at the church of the divine
child catholic church michigan
um reverend bob is cancelled for being
yet another spineless gutless skinless
nearly translucent
jellyfish-like creature masquerading as
a leader and shepherd of christ's flock
specifically reverend bob is cancelled
for apologizing for a good
truthful and necessary homily given by
his associate pastor
father paul graney at the 430 mass this
past saturday
apparently caused controversy by
speaking plainly and honestly
about antifa and blm here's a bit of
what
father granny said well these days if
you turn on the news or
open a newspaper or click on any news
source online the past
three four months or so you've seen
maybe some of the ugliest times in our
nation's
history people have been out in our
streets doing incredibly violent things
in the name of justice
cars have been torched property has been
destroyed
businesses looted and burned and police
officers
and other people have been intimidated
assaulted
and even murdered all in the name of
justice
often times rallying cry being no
justice
no peace well this past week just a
couple days ago
i think yesterday marked the 19th
anniversary of 9 11 when islamic
terrorists hijacked
passenger airplanes and flew them into
the world
trade center in new york city now father
granny went on to say that
al qaeda came with the goal to destroy
america little by little with acts of
terror but in 2020 many of our own
people are now
out there in the streets wanting to
remake america into something else by
destroying what it is today
little by little there's no great army
but it's a riot but it's riot by riot
now reading from the detroit news
article on this has a little bit more
information it says
grainy singled out two groups he said
intended to quote implement communism a
stateless classical society
one was antifa uh and then the other was
black lives
matter the associate pastor called the
first an anarchist terrorist
organization
and rejected the second as working
against the traditional family structure
and he read aloud from the blm website
from the pulpit
this is great um al qaeda's goal was to
come to the united states and kill
americans
really just wanted to wipe america off
the map quoting now from from father
granny
and they they would have done it if they
could but today those who
we see wanting to bring down america are
americans and they want to do it under
the facade of justice freedom and love
but it's all a bunch of baloney it's
anti-christian
it's anti-family it's evil that was the
humbling
everything you said there of course
entirely absolutely
undeniably true not just true it's a
necessary truth
that many christians in the pews need to
hear how do i know they need to hear it
well precisely because so many of them
apparently didn't want to hear it
they complained and cried and they said
that the mean priests made their tummies
hurt
and that's when reverend bob stepped in
and uh he
uh admonished the the the priest
publicly in a statement on facebook he
posted he said
uh i am so sorry that a homily given by
father paul graney at the 4 30 p.m mass
on saturday was has brought
forth division anger confusion and chaos
chaos there's chaos in the streets
because of this homily that a priest
gave in the 4 30 p.m mass in michigan
uh he said i spoke first with a couple
individuals shortly after this homily i
could sense their anger and their hurt
anger and hurt at what it's true
reverend bob
were they angry and hurt because the
truth that father granny shared was
difficult to hear were they angry and
hurt because the truth was politically
inconvenient to them and they don't want
others to find out about it
were they angry and hurt because well
you know what it doesn't matter
if you're angry and hurt by simply by
simple statements of truth
that's on you that's your problem
um it goes on here uh this is the more
of the statement mccabe said he he spoke
with granny quote to express my opinion
that his homily was not
pastoral or sensitive to all the people
who would be hearing it i also expressed
concern that he did not attend
did not mention any of the scriptures
proclaimed at mass a homily is supposed
to reflect on and break open the word of
god proclaimed
the next day grainy gave a pastorally
sound uh homily based on the scriptures
mccabe said
he went on to say as your pastor i want
to assure you that a divine child we
love and respect all persons
every person is sacred in the eyes of
god regardless of their race religion or
sexuality
at different times we need to focus on
our different groups and their
particular needs right now
the murder of countless persons of color
demands a clear response the entire
human family needs to unite in
confronting these injustices
we must protect the lives of persons of
color and be the voice for people who do
not have one
okay let me just say a few things here
first of all i can guarantee you
that this is the first time old bob has
ever had a problem with a priest
not citing the gospel during his homily
i tell you that right now
his concern here has nothing to do with
the priest's failure to break open the
word of god
as it happens one of the one of the
readings at mass last weekend
was sir act 27 30 which says quote
resentment and anger these are foul
things too and a sinner is a master at
them both
whoever exacts vengeance will experience
the vengeance of the lord
who keeps strict account of sin elm
is all about exacting vengeance for
perceived offenses committed against
them
it's all about resentment and anger
that's the entire movement
those are its guiding principles would
reverend bob have been okay with the
homily had father granny made this
explicit connection something tells me
he wouldn't have been
second the message delivered from the
pulpit
should not be sensitive to those who who
hear it if by
sensitive you mean concerned primarily
with protecting their
fragile feelings that is not what the
priest is there to do
that's not why the church exists that's
not why people walk through those doors
and if that is why they walk through the
doors to have their ears tickled and
their feelings protected
then it's better to scare them straight
slap some sense into them rather than
sacrifice
truth for their sake third
no in fact we do not need to hear
homilies about how the murder of persons
of color is bad
we don't need to hear the priest stand
up there and tell us that it's wrong for
racist white people to murder black
people
everybody knows that everyone agrees
with that everyone in the church
already fully and totally and completely
understands that
they don't need to be told there's
nothing more to be said on the subject
also it just so happens there is no such
epidemic as i've covered many times
those those kinds of murders are
extremely extremely extremely rare
and none of the high-profile police
killings in recent years have had any
established or even plausible link to
racism but aside from that
sermons against racism sermons against
white supremacists killing black people
sermons about the wonders of racial
unity
these are useless messages for the
reason that everybody already agrees
it's the same reason why i assume and i
would hope a priest isn't going to get
up there on the anniversary of d-day
and deliver a message explaining why the
nazis were bad
there was a time and place where such a
message was needed and real courage was
required to give it bonhoeffer is a good
example
but that time in place is not here
thankfully
so what a priest should be doing is
thinking to himself
what can i say to these people that they
might not already
know or might not fully understand what
is it that they actually need to hear
the only reason he should ask himself
what the congregation wants to hear is
just so he can rule those subjects out
completely
people can go anywhere to hear what they
want to hear much of the media in
hollywood and pop culture exists
precisely to scratch that itch
the church should not be in the giving
them what they want to hear business
it should be in the truth business the
hard truth business
the necessary truth business in fact if
you're a priest
and you give a homily and it doesn't
upset anybody in the pews
then it was probably a waste of time but
that's what the priest here did
he upset some people he spoke some truth
and of course the feckless coward
masquerading as a spiritual leader
apologized for it and for that he is
canceled but we should all we should all
uh
speaking of supporting people who
support us we should all support
christian leaders priests pastors
who actually do like this priest who get
up there and speak
um truth because here's here's the other
thing
they're gonna they're gonna have to deal
as we saw here they're gonna have to
deal with the wrath
from uh many of the cowards in the pews
and also
the cowards who are above them that's
what we saw here so
that priest is canceled the other priest
is uh is the opposite of canceled
whatever that is
we'll just we'll give him a round of
applause um we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there